"Viens tenter ta chance à Dead Park,"
"le nouveau parc d’attractions avec des zombies vraiment contaminés. "
"Zéro barrières, zéro limites, 100% frissons."
"Salut les petits loups, on est avec Amaury qui nous vient de Dinard …"
Oh mon gars, on a été à Dead Park ce weekend,
c’était DINGUE!
Tu sais c’est pas comme les parcs d’attractions à la con
où t’as les zombies qui sont foutus derrière des grillages
et qui te font rien, non!
Genre là, t’es avec eux, tu les vois,
et genre ils peuvent te chopper, ils peuvent t’agripper, quoi.
C’était génial.
Mais, ça va, t’es sûr?
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais!
Ouais, ça va, ouais.
Hahaha!
De la balle mon pote,
t’aurais trop du venir putain!
A un moment donné,
j’étais dans un couloir comme ça,
je me fais courser par un zombie,
il me poursuit, il me poursuit,
et il me saute dessus pour me bouffer.
Mais c’est passé à ça de mon oreille mon pote!
A ça !
Non les mecs, vous vous êtes fait mordre là.
Haha, n’importe quoi.
Mais non, c’est vachement encadré et tout,
y’a des vigiles, enfin voilà c’est un parc quoi.
Oh! Anecdote.
Je me retrouve à un moment face à deux zombies.
Viens, on dit, vas-y, toi tu fais moi,
et nous on fait les zombies.
Ah ouais ouais, c’est drôle ça.
Au début j’avais un pied de biche,
parce qu’au début ils te donnent un pied de biche
genre c’est la démerde quoi, tu vois.
Genre toi t’as un pied de biche.
ls te donnent un casque aussi, t’as un casque.
Et là je me retrouve face à eux,
je me planque derrière un petit muret.
Je sors et …
Fais style tu sors derrière la palissade,
tu fais moi. Et tu te planques derrière le mur.
Sors, vas-y, sors.
Ca va les gars?
Eh non ça va pas du tout là!
Mais si ça va!
On fait les zombies quoi!
Joue un peu le truc!
Bon, bref. Ils m’attaquent,
là, je perds mon pied de biche,
et là je me retrouve mais avec leur petites gueules
à ça de la mienne.
T’imagines pas le flippe putain.
Ah je peux pas!
Vous êtes des putains de zombies!
Oh!
Calme toi.
Non, lâche ce chapeau moche. Ca ne sert à …
Ah!
-Oh
Eh ouais.
T’es malade ou quoi? Qu’est-ce qu’il y a?
Tu poses le bras.
Fais attention avec ça, fais attention.
Je vous découpe,
je vous découpe les genoux.
Arrête. T’es clairement sous pression,
t’as vraiment besoin de calme.
Ça va très bien!
Ça va mieux que toi.
Tu poses ce bras.
Tu poses le plumeau.
Le bras d’abord.
Pose mon bras.
Voilà, en même temps, en même temps.
Léger décalé.
En décalé.
Légèrement décalé.
Ca va aller, ok? Ça va aller.
Je suis désolé, je comprends pas.
Mon amour!
ça va aller.
On rentre à la maison, d’accord?
En Seine-et-Marne, un jeune homme pris de démence soudaine
a menacé ses deux collègues à l’aide d’un …
Tout de suite, la météo.
A ce moment-là, je prends les ciseaux
et je les menace avec.
Mais bon,
là maintenant ça fait un an,
et ça va beaucoup mieux.
Merci les mecs.
Eh les gars, eh.
C’est pas souvent qu’on est ensemble.
On prend une photo?
Ah oui!
Attention!
On va passer à l’étape des lentilles de contact.
C’est la première fois de ma vie que je vais en mettre.
Ca devrait bien se passer.
Woah, la misère.
Ca se voit pas là que j’en chie ?
Vous êtes sûr que j’aurais le visage de Bradley Cooper après ?